foreign
[Music]
everyone I'm Josh Welsh president of
film independent and welcome to a very
special edition of film independent
presents we are so excited to be having
a conversation today about bad acts and
with the filmmakers
um and to moderate today's Con well
before we get to moderating let me just
say thank you to Vision media our
streaming partner to the hfpa for their
support and to IFC for making today
possible uh with that I want to turn
this over to the one and only Eva
Longoria who will be moderating today's
conversation Eva thank you so much for
being here and I'll turn it over to you
thank you so much for having me I'm so
happy and honored to host this
conversation
um this documentary is spectacular and
it spoke to me in my my heart in so many
ways
um and I want to thank uh Daniel because
he's the one that exposed me to this
beautiful film and uh and made me aware
of uh this story
um so thank you Daniel Day Kim for for
bringing me along for the ride uh he'll
be on the panel uh along with our
director producer DP David C
um and of course David and Rachel from
the film
um I'm gonna say the log line just in
case anybody wants to be reminded but
bad ax captures a closely knit
Asian-American family living in rural
Michigan
uh and they fight or to keep their
American Dream alive and as owners of a
local prominent restaurant they reckon
with a global pandemic racial tensions
and generational scars from cambodia's
Killing Fields there's so much in this
documentary I wanna I wanna just start
by by uh saying congratulations uh David
this is no small feat
um you must be really proud of the final
product I mean this is such an intimate
story what do you want to say to anybody
who's already watched it who hasn't
watched it
no that thank you Eva for for you know
taking the time to moderate this
conversation today and for taking time
to watch the film I mean you know bad X
is such an incredibly personal story and
um you know one I always really wanted
to share like you know about my family
and uh you know the fact that the film
is is out there now and it's it's
resonating with you know it seems like
audiences everywhere across the country
it's it feels so special and I'm so
grateful you know like to have made just
something that was so personal to me and
have it be so Universal at the same time
and
um speaking about just the larger themes
you know that uh you know not only our
family has gone through these past
couple years but in our entire country
so
um it really is just incredible to just
put the story out there now and
um be able to hear other people's
stories you know back after they get a
chance to watch you know the film yeah
well I am such a document memory fan I I
would I'll watch a documentary about
about rocks like I just love getting to
know uh things and people and stories
and I love how documentaries really
humanize issues and I feel like you hit
upon so many issues and the pandemic
kind of magnifies all these issues
um and that kind of what you explore in
the documentary uh I've I've made
documentaries I've directed
documentaries and one thing I when I
when I direct a documentary I have to
have a center theme because
documentaries can go 80 000 directions
if you let it right like especially in
the editing room and so what did you
choose to focus on like what was your
North Star when you were uh thinking of
doing this obviously it's your family so
you're a little biased already with like
what I want to show and what I maybe I
don't want to show
but but what was your North Star like
what was your Guiding Light in in this
this is this is what I'm going to tell
this is this is the theme I'm going to
explore I you know it there was I guess
a lot of efforts you know when you start
making a documentary you're right like
there's so many themes that like you
you're being pulled in so many different
directions of how to explore this and
how do I want to you know talk about
this issue and you know what I always
came back to was exactly what you said
it was family but I think it's also like
this American Dream Story I mean
um you know just you think about my
family you know like a Mexican-American
woman a Cambodian Refugee who just came
here with the shirt on his back in 1979
I mean these were two passionate
individuals that decided of all places
to settle you know in bad ax Michigan
and open up a donut shop and you know
struggle so hard for years before being
able to turn it around into a successful
restaurant I mean like that's an
American Dream story right there so even
prior to the pandemic
um I always wanted to tell that story
and I didn't know it would be a
documentary I always thought I would
like write a script yeah I would tell
like a narrative you know version of
that story
um but in those early days I I sat down
with you know my mom and my dad and you
know just got this whole oral history of
like okay how did the restaurant come to
be what it is today in the town of badax
um thinking that was just gonna be again
research for me to write a script
um but like this other side of me like
I'm I'm always a kid who grew up like
with cameras and filming my family
um so you know as a board unemployed
filmmaker who just came home from New
York you know I had a lot of free time
on my hands and I just wanted to you
know I knew it was an important time we
were living in and I just wanted to like
I guess have like these memories to hold
on to like just really Home Videos so it
kind of just started off as like home
videos and I think you know the point
where I realized like I was shooting a
documentary and this American Dream
story that I've been wanting to tell for
so long that I was actually in the
middle of making it I think it was like
around like the black lives matter
movement
um when you know it just became very
clear that like
the American dream is something we have
to fight for so hard during this really
uncertain time that we're living through
and what better way to tell this
American Dream store I wanted to share
all along than than In This Very
consequential time where everything is
being challenged I mean everyone was
going through it it wasn't just you know
our family or our restaurant it was so
yeah it was like you know it was like
the whole world's in a sense and it just
became the perfect backdrop to tell this
American Dream story so yeah it was it
was coming back to family in the
American dream like that was that was a
Guiding Light I feel like for me the
point of view and so Daniel Day Kim and
I I think we share the same brain and
heart a lot of the times because we we
Champion the same issues we care about
the same things we have the same Daniel
spoke one time on a panel I was on and
we both had this idea about you know
we're minorities we're minorities in a
country
and you know about the model minority
right and like we have to be a certain
way we have to do a certain thing so
Daniel I when when you brought this film
to my attention I was like of course
you're eping this this is like right up
your alley this is like obviously I mean
this film's gonna speak to everybody's
heart but what what how did you come
into this equation
well uh I saw the film uh just like you
and uh you know David and Rachel and his
family had already completed it and they
were looking for help to get it out
there uh be into the mainstream and you
know that's when people like you and me
come in Eva and and that's why your help
is so incredibly uh valuable and where
everyone is so grateful for it but uh I
saw the film and you're absolutely right
it was right in my wheelhouse it was all
the things that you and I talk about all
the time uh and you know we talk about
intersectionality uh cross-cultural
intersectionality you know as themes for
our society and we look for projects
that kind of highlight those ideas
because I think what we're both looking
for is unity and Harmony among all of us
we're not saying that you know uh Asian
American stories or Latin American
stories are the only stories to tell
we're looking for a way to contextualize
them in the American story uh as part as
an important part of the American story
and this happened to be
completely in that vein you know and it
happened to be organic because we talk
about these things thematically but we
have in this family in the Civ family
everything that we're talking about
embodied organically in in a place of
love and so so I thought this this story
should be told we're talking about the
American dream we're talking about
intersectionality we're talking about uh
Asian Americans a Mexican-American in
the face of BLM black lives matter this
is all of us right and in the in in the
wake of Colvin not in the wake of covet
in the midst of covid and so that's what
could be more Universal than all of us
struggling to make a living and finding
our way during a pandemic uh a global
pandemic so uh it just spoke to me in a
lot of different ways and I love the way
um this family navigated all of these
obstacles and continues to navigate and
tries to thrive and pursue their
American Dream it's it's something for
all of us uh in in that sense everyone
who lives in America is struggling
with all these things and as we as we
approach elections are actually maybe by
the time this year heirs we will have
had the elections you know the it's a
referendum on how we are all
making a living and how we are trying to
survive and this story Illustrated all
of that so eloquently yeah that's one
thousand percent what I felt when I saw
the film was
um what we don't have enough of in this
country is empathy empathy for where
people came from what they went through
what they're going through
um what it takes to I mean starting a a
small business much less a restaurant is
probably the hardest thing to do
anywhere in the world
um much less you know in in bad acts
Michigan and obviously there's a
cultural specificity to to your family
uh David and Rachel but I I love when
you can see the origin story of anybody
you know the reality of human migration
is really put into context in this film
and I think that it makes makes me fall
in love with with your family right away
but also makes me understand and I go
yeah I get it now I get it I understand
it
um you know and I love the way your
family comes together for the American
dream did you do you feel I don't know I
mean you've had you guys have had you've
done the the festival circuit uh and
you've had over you know all these
Awards and all these amazing attention
what have you seen in regards to what
audiences are receiving from the film
well first of all I want to say thank
you so much for you know uh being with
us today it really means the world to
our whole family
um but yeah it I think that's been the
most um
uh interesting part for us to be able to
hear and listen to other people's
stories you know isn't that they
resonate with one of us in the family
whether it's you know the mom or my
husband or David or or Jacqueline the
oldest sister or Kyle the youngest
sister or just the restaurant yeah it's
when people you know say that they see
themselves yes that's that's been one of
the most
um rewarding experiences is to you know
connect with all the people that we come
in contact with yeah and it's you know
it's like just what you're saying like
it's like it's like humanizing these
issues and like you know I feel like you
know we're at this as a country right
now where it's so easy just to look at
each other as that's the other side
right but you know what when people get
a chance to see this film it's like
witnessing firsthand that like no
they're they're opening up their hearts
and their minds to not just looking at
this like oh this is this Progressive
liberal family living in conservative
America it's like no these are just
members of the community and you know
and fellow Americans you know just like
anyone else in the community of bad X
um if I could just add really quickly
it's a it's it's a fully fleshed out
picture too you're you're not making
your family out to be Saints David yeah
and that's so important none of us are
perfect and you know once neither one
side is not a saint the other side is
not the sinner it's we're all just human
and I love the way your your film
highlighted all of that thank you thank
you and you know we had the chance to
actually show this film in bad acts uh
of May of this past year
um it was like right after our world
premiere South by Southwest
um we put together just like a small
local screening that was really for like
a lot of the community members who
helped
um donate to the films you know
crowdfunding campaign
um but we ended up having you know like
probably 20 or 30 open seats that we
gave to the general public and most of
the people who fill those open seats
were actually like the skeptical people
like these were the individuals that
were commenting on the Rachel's social
media page and literally stopping my mom
like in our local Walmart telling you
know telling her we're not going to
support the business anymore because of
what your son is doing I mean you know
those were and at that time did you see
the movie yet yeah no no one did no one
saw the movie yet but so we were we were
really nervous for that evening but you
know after the the credits rolled and
the lights came up
um the film was just that was so much
genuine love just not only from the
people in that room who helped make it
possible but you know from a lot of
those individuals who were you know very
wary of like what this film how is going
to paint bad acts
um and then you know afterwards it it
that was that was the beginning of like
just being and had conversations because
pretty much every single one of those
individuals came up to us afterwards and
they said I'm sorry yeah so it was you
know I'm sorry for they said I'm sorry
for judging your family and your story
before I had the chance to see it for
myself self and I think they began to
look at us you know they began to have
empathy and began to look at us as their
fellow community members and that's how
you know in order for change to happen
there needs to be a dialogue but in
order for a dialogue to start we need to
be able to like talk with each other as
like human beings and see each other as
you know fellow community members
um and that was just so powerful as we
continue to you know be on this Festival
run and like actually having these
conversations
um you know it's a start right and
change happens at a very slow pace
whether we like it or not but like being
able just to speak with one another and
talk about our experiences and not be
discredited
um you know that that's that's just been
one of I think the most special things
about being on this journey so far is
people feeling represented and people
being willing to to have a dialogue yeah
but Rachel what what's happened what's
the reaction you you've gotten
specifically with with screenings and
people coming up to you
what's their opinion it's you know it's
been all over the board which is really
cool because you get to hear so many
different
um perspectives on what they got out of
the the movie or what they saw and
honestly I just have to say connecting
with their you know feelings of like how
did you
um you know
raise such a you know outspoken children
and I said well that's something that
was really important for my husband and
I
um when we had our children
um unfortunately for myself you know I
you know being Mexican-American it's one
of the things I have a big regret is I
never even learned to speak Spanish
because our parents didn't want us to
you know yes because we couldn't it was
just because they didn't want us to you
know
um
standing out uh you know they wanted to
assimilate yeah so you know raising our
children completely different and and
seeing their how how
um
you know just just seeing how outspoken
and for the right reasons you know for
what is right it really be proud to have
children that could speak their minds
and but I think from a lot of hard
conversations between each other you
know yeah it didn't just happen because
well it's like Jacqueline says in the
film you know like my parents like they
they were taught to follow this model
minority you know methods keep your head
down show up to work and you'll succeed
as long as you work hard right whereas
like I I feel like you know through a
lot of hard conversations
um we've learned that like you know our
generation yeah I think that's what
changed me the most to you know before
if I would hear like a racial comment or
whatever
then you know move along uh both my own
business but now I'm I stand up you know
like why would you say that she does
yeah you know that's not very nice or
you know you wouldn't like people to
talk to you like that so it's changed me
in in a sense and and that as well so
yeah yeah yeah
killed and taught me but they taught us
though too it's like we teach I don't
know I feel like you you and Papa have
always taught us to like just do the
right thing yeah what's what's right
that that's such a crucial part of the
film too the intergenerational uh views
and perspectives on the American dream
listening to your father tell his story
and his and his beliefs about uh guns
vis-a-vis the way you guys feel about
guns and the way you feel about
assimilation versus the way that your
mom feels about assimilation and she was
taught these are all these are all
really important uh parts of the story
to tell as well yeah
so true it's so funny because I didn't
grow up speaking Spanish either I I
learned late in life I was like you know
40 when I learned Spanish
um but there is uh you know this idea of
what a Mexican-American looks like of
what an Asian American looks like of
what and and we're so it's so much more
than that and we're so layered and we're
so you know and the fact that we're
American as well like we you know
at the end of the day you know and
that's what I like about about the film
as well sorry what were you going to say
David no I I said you you said it
exactly was like you know when I wanted
to like when I think about like what I
want people to like take away from this
film one of the key things for me is
like opening up this
um idea of like what the American
Experience is because
you know the Asian American Experience
of Mexican-American like that's all part
of the American experience at the end of
the day I mean America is a country
that's built on refugees and immigrants
and
um our experiences you know of being
American it's it's just as American as
any of our neighbors yes and you know we
we just so appreciate you know we
have people like
you for example you know making the
footprints that we can follow in so we
can you know make our stories come out
too so thank you let me tell you
speaking about multi-generational views
if you want to disappoint your parents
tell them you're going to be an actor
we paid for you to go to college and
you're gonna do what
um yeah yeah or or a filmmaker right you
know yeah my dad says look as long as
you get into the University of Michigan
you can study whatever the heck you want
and when I told them I'm gonna study
film he's like oh my God I should have I
should have put more stipulations on
this
yeah let me tell you let me do I was the
I was the uh uh I'm the um underachiever
in my family for sure I mean my I come
from a family of Educators and and so
yeah I get that that I did like that too
Daniel that that multi-generational
point of view with um what does success
mean what does success look like right
um and so I think a lot of people are
gonna are gonna relate to that
um I wanted to ask Daniel what do you
hope people get from this film
uh that despite our challenges despite
our obstacles we can do this together
that's that's really what I would really
love to take away and I don't mean it
you know I mean it as a society writ
large but I also mean it as families
like we can we you know we all face the
pandemic we all as families have to have
difficult conversations sometimes with
our parents or our children or our our
sisters and brothers because even within
families we all know that we don't
always agree right but you know this
idea of thinking of all of us as a
community one filled with empathy and
the the the desire to understand one
another I think is something that we can
extend beyond our families to the
communities and our neighbors who live
around us and bad acts is a microcosm of
our country you know the bad acts I
consider to be the front line of you
know cultural differences in in our
country country and and actually the
world if you think about it with uh the
recent elections in in various countries
around the world but but yeah so I I
like this idea of hope I I really hope
that we can find a way to consider our
communities our families and our
neighbors and and so we we seek to
understand them as well as to be
understood no I love that Daniel because
I you know we always say it's like if
you know if people walk away with this
hope that we can just begin to just have
these tough dialogue conversations and
you see this happen within the family
uncomfortable conversations that he's
you have to have them and if the said
family can do it hopefully there's a a
bigger takeaway there that you know um
we can do that within our own
communities you know like like bad acts
just like anywhere else you know in the
US so and what better symbolism than a
restaurant where everyone could come and
break bread together you know despite
your opinions and your different
differing opinions that at the end of
the day you come together other and
share what we all have in common yeah
it's so funny because I was going to say
that narratively if you did this
narratively you you would have made it
up and put them in a restaurant you know
what I mean like you didn't have to this
was like where would where could I place
this family
same question Eva what would you say
after seeing this film oh gosh
um you know I think specifically with
the pandemic like I said you know it
really
put a magnifying glass on on that the
fact that we live in a global Community
right like this tiny invisible virus
affected every single person in the
world
um and so you should think about world
issues that way you know what's
happening in Iran right now with the
women in Iran it's it's very dangerous
for us what the war in the Ukraine will
have an effect on us like we live in a
global community so you I agree with you
that the bad acts is this microcosm of
the globe and how we're all connected we
all got to get along we I gotta we all
got to figure this out right uh how do
we how do we co-exist
um and so I do think you know for for me
the big the big message is like
what is success you know how how you
guys pulled together as a family
um just thematically any any themes that
any themes to deal with with family is
super relatable to me you know if it's a
a family member that's going through
cancer you get that you get like oh how
we're all gonna rally around that if
it's the restaurant how we all going to
figure this out
um you know anything that has to do you
know it's if somebody's getting divorced
okay let's figure out the children and
like everybody gets they understand
these things because we all we all go
through them and so I just think I think
point of view is really important in
documentaries and your point of view
being specifically Asian American
Mexican-American like your point of view
nobody else could tell this story and
that's what makes it beautiful and
unique and painted by by your brush like
it's so beautiful thank you thank you um
I wanted to ask you I know we're running
out of time but I wanted to ask you was
there any
point in which you were going to stop
like you were filming and going this is
going to be nothing this is leading to
Nowhere what am I doing no because more
than your family or that your family was
like could you please stop with the
camera oh yeah well like with with them
like they were always kind of used to me
just always having a camera around and
you know granted some of like those you
know more emotional moments there were
times where it was like put the camera
down you know
um but I don't think it was ever like a
question of like whether to continue
filming or not because that's just
something I have always done
um I think where it really became a
conversation and where
um trust and became really important you
know between director and subjects in
this case my family was when we I
actually started like editing the film
together and you know it's when you take
300 plus hours of footage and start
crafting you know your family members
and these characters with these arcs and
these flaws you know what I mean then
that's when you know I have a very
opinionated family and that's when you
know everyone wanted to give their notes
on the film
you are not putting that you're not
putting on it you know and like
um and you know I will say like this
this really was like a family project in
the sense where I did try and listen to
every single family member every single
editor every single producer
um because collaboration I think is just
so important and as I mean as both of
you know in the filmmaking process
um and you know bad X was was no
exception you know as personal as as it
is I think the reason why the film has
come together and has that sense of
family feel in the end of it is because
I did take away a little from what every
single person in my family said from my
very opinionated sister Jacqueline to my
dad you know like it really was just an
all-in uh group effort so who gets Final
Cut who who gets it
but you know I think by the time they
they saw the film and
um you know these emotional moments that
you know like Daniel was saying like it
does we're not perfect people right but
like that's so important to when you're
when you're painting people as humans
you need to show them as a
three-dimensional people they are and so
by the time I think everyone saw the
final cut it was like oh you know it all
made sense as to like why
everything needed to be included in
there yeah yeah well I applaud you for
this uh you know project because making
a documentary is not easy and you made
it look easy it looked like oh this yeah
it's his family of course he knows this
and I know it's not but but that's what
the final product looks like so
congratulations it is a beautiful film I
hope everybody sees it I hope it reaches
everybody's Hearts because it's it's the
message of it is so important for us to
receive right now
no thank you thank you so much we really
appreciate that yeah and thank you again
for you to be here talking about this
with David and Rachel and me it means
the world and it just speaks to all the
things that I've always known about you
and your willingness to give and uh I uh
it just only heightens my level of
respect and love for you oh thank you so
much I I owe it to you for bringing me
uh making me aware of this project it's
so hard to get exposed to these films
that are so great you're like I never
saw it it was like I'm a festival
circuit it wasn't distributed it was it
on Netflix like you're just like so the
fact that I I was exposed to it is the
gift so I I thank you for that that's um
yeah and it's it's hard to get anything
made and even put out there I mean I'll
share that you know nine months ago
um I have the
101.99 in my bank account and uh this
was like a week before our South by
Southwest Premiere and pretty much every
sales agent and you know distributor
they pass on us and that was so
disheartening going into like a big
Festival like this because we just
didn't know if there was going to be an
audience to connect with this film uh
luckily you know someone in the room you
know was there at IFC and you know the
next week we got an offer and I was able
to pay my rent that month which is you
know all great and uh and just being on
this journey now even just you know it's
very surreal just even talking with the
most of you when I picked up a camera
two years ago I just never would have
expected we'd be here and I'm just
grateful for that right now we're here
right now yeah I'm just waiting here
finding an audience so no thank you let
me tell you I I really think that that's
why the film is so special is because
when you set out when you have a purpose
of something that's not monetary or not
a money grab or not like I'm gonna make
something that makes money like that
never works you know what I mean but
when you set out to go I really want to
tell this story you know and I want this
to be the message success comes because
the authenticity behind that intention
is so pure and so beautiful that uh you
were bound to have success with this and
this is just the beginning thank you
thank you I that means a lot coming from
you for real that's true if things go as
as we hope you'll have many more
conversations like these with many more
people like us
oh we hope so we hope so no thank you
thank you so much David and Rachel and
Daniel thanks for this conversation
thank you yeah really it's our honor
thank you thank you everyone
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]